why did that make you smile
why'd you smile one of the names of god
from the islamic tradition is that he's
the loving one
because many christians don't know that
muslims love jesus because a muslim
cannot be a muslim unless they believe
in revere love and respect
all of the prophets including jesus just
name the mosque and i'll i'll get you an
invitation that's not only willing eager
one of our hopes
okay is that people embrace islam and
become muslims that's why this
conversation was so important
[Music]
come on jordan peterson now you've been
delivered a true testify that there's
nothing worthy of worship except the
creator of the heavens and the earth
[Music]
how are you guys doing go ahead and hit
that like button so we can go ahead and
build some traction and help get this
message out to the world subscribe hit
that notification bell very very
important
so you are not left behind when new
videos come out just like this one now i
was looking forward to talking to
muhammad hijab himself
inshallah we set a date for sometime in
january to have him on the program back
on the dean's show to talk about his
interview with
jordan peterson
now much respect goes out to mr jordan
peterson who's mr jordan peterson
well he's a professor of psychology
he's a clinical psychologist
and a best-selling author
and he was
courageous enough man enough
to go ahead
and do what many
failed to do
talk to muslims not about
muslims learn about islam instead of
talking about islam
and
he stepped up and much respect
for you mr jordan peterson much respect
inshallah god willing others following
your footsteps now i want to get into
this beautiful conversation back and
forth with
jordan peterson and muhammad it was a
very affable
enlightening
amazing conversation
well so i'm going to ask some some
really basic questions wants to ask
basic questions
because the the it's very difficult to
understand another culture from the
outside he talks about you have no idea
how much you don't know about what you
don't know you're blind to your own
ignorance for as an outsider you have no
idea how much you don't know about what
you don't know even you're blind to your
own ignorance he admits that he doesn't
have a tangible understanding of islam
and so i'm going to start with basic
questions
i don't i wouldn't say that i have a
tangible understanding of islam look how
intelligent this man is the kind of
degrees that he is the professor in
academia and he's coming out sincerely
and he's coming out it seems like he's
authentic in what he's saying he's
genuinely sincere and he's coming out
and saying he has a religious
system a system of thought islam has
remained relatively opaque to me he
talks about how he's done a reasonable
amount of historical reading despite the
fact that i've done a reasonable amount
of historical reading and so where did
he get this information where are people
getting the information from as a
legitimate question a very important
question i mean time magazine did an
article in 1979
that talked about in a span of a hundred
fifty years
60 000 books were written against islam
by the islamophobia by the hate machine
so was he reading some of those books
because you can read 100 200 books but
it was one of one of these books
you know compared to one real authentic
book
written by a mainstream muslim scholar
right someone who has some credibility
you could throw all these 200 300 in the
garbage at the end you come back to
you got we got to come down like
somebody when he comes in to learn from
i'm a professor of gracie brazilian
jiu-jitsu a lot of times it's harder to
reach teach someone who comes in and
learns you know on his own in the wrong
way now he comes in we got to fix up all
the mistakes rather than someone comes
blank so many people
like the jordan petersons and others
they're getting the wrong information
but much respect to jordan peterson that
he's being humble and he's being sincere
that he really is starting from the
basics he wants to know the basics
what do you what what is it what is it
in terms of practice and belief that are
absolutely core as far as you're
concerned to
practicing the islamic faith and
mohammed hijab gives him the bare bone
basics
well the first thing is i think we
should start with the bare bones basics
and this is just a reminder how the
misinformation has permeated the world
it's saturated all over the place with
the lies misinformation half truths
distortion deliberate distortions the
list goes on
and the it's very sad that the naive
credulous majority have swallowed all
this hook line and sinker so in fact
i will actually argue today that the new
testament representation of jesus christ
in his second coming is way more violent
than muhammad's
conquests in uh the medina okay the term
warlord that you use with the prophet
you've never used with harry truman
you've never used with uh
with uh roosevelt you've never used with
winston churchill all of which conquered
countries literally in wars that's why
this conversation was so important and
much of respect goes out to george
peterson hopefully others will follow in
this example
and the barebones basics is first to say
that we believe in god so it's beautiful
the beginning right away starts with the
pure monotheism the tolheed that there's
nothing no one worthy of worship except
the creator of the heavens and earth god
almighty allah near make allah
is one god
worthy of worship when we say allah you
know that the jews and christians for
arabic speaking they also use the term
allah it's in the bible in the first
book of genesis allah this is what
christians would believe is like thief
the father in heaven this is the creator
god almighty allah so nothing is worthy
of worship except the one creator not
your ideas not your desires not a human
being not the money you make not the
material possessions not the material
things not your ancestors nothing is
worthy of worship except the one who
created you god almighty allah so it's
beautiful
how he starts off with this belief that
nothing is worthy of worship except the
one god allah the pure monotheism the
tawheed alhamdulillah one god
uh worthy of worship let's go into the
next clip where muhammad hijab this is
you know kind of sensitive and you're
worried about you know uh if you're
gonna offend somebody but our brother
muhammad hijab goes and addresses
something that's very important he talks
about the trinity now what we would say
though sorry to kind of drag this on a
little bit is that this would disqualify
something like the trinity from being
true and in fact the quran this is the
islamic position
is vehement in its uh opposition towards
a triune god so for example in chapter
23 verse 91 it says
that god hasn't taken the son and he
doesn't have any gods with him if that
had been the case each god would have
taken what he has created and they would
have tried to dominate one another
the idea therefore that there can be
more than one all-powerful entity is an
inconceivable and unintelligible idea
from the islamic paradigm so it's seen
as
problematic to say the least or
conceptually impossible to say even more
to suggest that something like a trinity
can be true
one is talking about for example
mary and jo mary and jesus it says
something very simple
yet anytime that both of them used to
eat food so in other words the
impossibility of something limited like
jesus
a man being god at the same time this
next clip is real interesting the point
about spark of divinity like you know
many people think that they can have a
little bit of divineness in them i mean
this is something that needs to be cut
from the root because divinity only
belongs to the creator the heavens and
earth do you think that there's a divine
spark in human beings
no but we don't think there's any kind
of divinity at all isla islam is
categorical about this because the way
we define divinity is extremely strict
we say that the divine attributes of god
are specific only to god now this next
part is extremely important like he did
defining the words how many times were
using words
islam and people you know the average
person has no idea what you're saying
they're like why are you using these
arabic words why don't you just speak
english definitions with god people
don't realize this especially from the
christian tradition but one of the names
of god from the islamic tradition is
that he's the loving one al-wadud in
arabic in the quran as well so we
believe that the relationship that human
being should have with god is a loving
relationship but
it's one of submission this is the main
thing islam doesn't mean peace islam
actually means submission islam comes
from the root arabic word islam and what
it means is submission because if
someone like jordan peterson who's
humble enough sincere enough to say look
let's start from the from the basic
basics he doesn't know
as read as he is he doesn't know so you
have to take people like the prophet
saws said talk to people according to
their level of understanding and the
majority of people know nothing about
islam everything in the universe is
submitting to god
everything the laws of nature have been
placed there by the law maker which is
god and this was the beautiful thing
about islam it's not something esoteric
obstrues hard to understand it's clear
it's simple this is the meta narrative
of islam abraham came moses came jesus
came and all of them came with exactly
the same message and that message is to
worship to believe in one god and to
worship in only one god look you have
the six articles of faith
this is what we believe that there's
only one and only one god he's only the
only one worthy of worship belief in the
angels and the messengers who went and
conveyed the message who were given the
books the divine scriptures the torah
the injil the quran which is the living
miracle that we have
testable the day of judgment
predestination and then what's the
actions the five pillars of islam
testifying come on jordan peterson now
you've been delivered the truth
testified that there's nothing worthy of
worship except the creator of the
heavens and the earth and muhammad is
his last and final messenger and then
you'll establish the prayer five times a
day at this fixed times then you'll fast
during the month of ramadan you'll give
the poor dutes the sakat and inshallah
one day you'll be making hajj with
brother muhammad hijab with me with all
of us with your brothers over
two billion muslims worldwide you'll be
entering the family these are the five
pillars alhamdulillah we have to
voluntarily
submit to god jordan peterson gets into
this quality admits that we're created
to
he talks about imitate and i do believe
that there's compelling evidence
psychological and biological yeah that
we human beings have a remarkably strong
instinct to imitate but not imitate the
kim kardashians not imitate the kanye
west and the jay-z's in the 55 cents no
no no it's very sad that many people end
up you know because those are the
modern-day idols icons that people end
up imitating and almost like worshiping
but the messengers were those who were
sent for us to imitate and muhammad
peace and blessings be upon him jesus at
his time was meant to be followed not
worshipped
moses as his time was meant to be
followed not worshipped and muhammad
peace and blessings be upon them all
he's the last and final messenger he's
meant to be followed and the question is
well what is it that we're oriented to
imitate there's a verse a beautiful ayah
in the quran where god almighty is
saying
to him
if you really love allah if you really
love god almighty then follow me and
allah will love you and forgive your
sins so if you follow if you really love
god almighty you have to follow the
prophet muhammad peace and blessings be
upon him because he is a brother to
jesus moses abraham he's the last and
final messenger he is the one teaching
you showing you how to get to paradise
how to have the most noble character
how to know god so you can love god he
is the example the best the mercy for
mankind prophet muhammad peace and
blessings be upon him so those are the
ones we imitate well hang on hang on a
sec i'm not i don't want it i don't want
to knock it you even had the prophecy
that's in the bible that he covered
beautiful alhamdulillah there are clear
verses in the bible like for example we
point to isaiah 42 11
where there indicates a new prophet
that's going to come and in fact isaiah
42 11 in particular is extremely
important because it even specifies the
region
it says it will be sent to the people of
kedar
and the people of kedar as in genesis
kedar was the son of ishmael and
basically from him is the lineage of
muhammad or the arabs if you like and so
it is a whole discussion in the whole of
isaiah 42 about a new prophet going to
come and he is going to come to the
people of kedar and the people will be
rejoicing on the mountaintops and in
fact the name of a mountain in medina
which is present-day saudi arabia is
mentioned which is the mount of salah
this part of the discussion was
extremely important because many
christians don't know that muslims love
jesus that you cannot be a muslim unless
you love and revere jesus as the messiah
as muhammad hijab goes on to say in many
ways we are all followers of christ and
that's another point of commonality like
we we see the messiah jesus christ as a
man
who had done wonders in miracles and
signs as the bible states we believe
that he was immaculately conceived we
believe that he cured the blind he
raised the dead with god's permission we
believe all like most of the things that
you'll find
we actually believe in those things
there's huge commonalities between islam
and christianity from that perspective
now you have a bd i have a bd a birth
date we have a departure date but god
almighty the creator allah has no the
the major difference is we would say
that it's not intelligible or
conceivable or pardonable to believe any
human being with a date of birth could
never be called god birth date and no
human being who has a zip code an area
code or in this case a bd can be god
and and this is where where we kind of
diverge from the christian mainstream so
it's beautiful to see that he pretty
much went over all the fundamentals this
is very important to all of the viewers
when you're sharing this dean
when you're sharing it
it's very important we call it the omg
oh my god
oh for the oneness of god the tall heed
you talk about this am
the messenger ship because a muslim
cannot be a muslim unless they believe
in revere love and respect
all of the prophets including jesus
moses abraham and all of them
follow all of them and in their way and
once again we believe that they were
divinely inspired that god almighty out
of his love his mercy being the one who
wants to guide humanity he sent the
messengers
and then the g for guidance he talks
about the quran this is the final
revelation sent to mankind you cannot go
ahead and bypass it thinking you're
going to go get to god almighty the
creator now if you're somebody living in
a jungle and the message didn't get
delivered to you that's a different
story you probably
like they talk about this innate nature
would raise you up to worship one and
only one god but you now is a different
story you're hearing about the quran
you're hearing the evidence that's being
presented different case different story
and he alhamdulillah addresses this
point very good about the quran that
submission is actually impossible
without a guidance and the guidance we
believe obviously is the quran
but we also acknowledge the we also
acknowledge the torah the original torah
that was sent to moser moses and the
original injil or the gospel that was
sent to
jesus but what we have is we can call it
a doctrine of taharif which means
corruption so what we believe is that
what happened is with these books you've
had
basically corruption happen to them so
we don't know what is uh what is part of
that book and what is not part of that
book we don't know exactly what jesus
said and what isn't they also had a very
nice breaking the ice moment when there
was a prophecy
when
jordan peterson asked muhammad hijab so
why are you smiling why did that make
you smile
why'd you smile it was a very nice
moment and then problem and then
muhammad talks about the prophecy that's
actually being fulfilled today we see
islam being the fastest growing way of
life in the world and this is a prophecy
that's being fulfilled
because
because that would make me happy i mean
quite quite openly and honestly because
we want the best
i mean to be honest with you if you want
to be totally honest yeah now that's
what i'm hoping for yeah all right
why you asking before we start the show
i mean one of our not objectives but one
of our hopes
okay is that people embrace islam and
become muslims
that's islam is an evangelizing religion
it's a religion which aims literally to
enter every home there's a there is
actually a prophetic saying that says
that islam will enter every home not
necessarily meaning everyone become
muslim but it will enter every home in
some way shape or form you mean like
what's happening right now with this
podcast
there you have it
it's part of it he goes ahead and lets
him hear the quran this was one of the
most powerful moments of the
interview sure okay do what you will so
the quran states in the end of chapter
59
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our friend our brother in humanity this
is so important
for you to understand and all of your
followers and just humanity in general
that the quran is a guidance
for you
for all of us the quran here's allah
that there is no god worthy of worship
except for him the king the holy the one
free from all defects the giver of
security the watcher over his creatures
the mighty the compeller the supreme
glory be to him glory be to god high is
he above all that they associate as
partners with him he is allah the
creator the inventor of all things the
bestower of forms to him belong the best
names all that is in the heavens and the
earth glorify him and he is the almighty
the all wise and this last parse was
very very
nice to see and we invite everybody to
visit your local mosque and we invite
the muslims to go ahead and open
your masjids have open houses so we have
jordan peterson
eager
not just looking forward to but eager
jordan peterson is eager
to visit
the mosque the masjids just name the
mosque and i'll i'll get you an
invitation i'm certainly willing to do
it that's not only willing eager and i
mean that i mean eager i would love to
be welcomed in that manner that would be
a tremendous privilege as far as i'm
concerned and the muslims are excited
later to welcome him i think you will be
surprised as to the amount of
acceptability that you have in
particular the muslim community so come
on jordan peterson we're looking forward
to seeing you in the masjid in hamas
and there's one thing left advice we
give you to do very simple very simple
there's a statement
that god almighty is saying narrated
through prophet muhammad peace and
blessed be upon him that god almighty is
saying that all my slaves are misguided
unless i guide them unless god guides
them so ask me of my guidance that's the
homework we leave you and everybody out
there to do ask the creator the heavens
and earth because sometimes a person can
get crippled
they can get held back by all their
intelligence because they end up
worshiping their mind their selves they
end up thinking that now they get ahead
of themselves let's call it
but
to be guided you need to ask for the
guidance
so go ahead and ask for the guidance
from the creator that heavens and earth
directly without no intermediary say god
almighty the creator the one who created
me guide me guide me guide me what do
you have to lose but everything to gain
and make sure to stay tuned we got
inshallah god willing we set a date for
some time in january to go deeper into
this with muhammad hijab his interview
with jordan peter said so subscribe
right now get that notification bell so
you don't miss that show and the many
others they'll come out
and then you miss it and you don't
benefit don't forget to pick up your
free copy of the crown for jordan
peterson if you'd like one go to
thedeenshow.com or anyone else out there
go ahead visit thedeenshow.com and we'll
get one out there
directly to you thank you very much
peace be with you assalamu alaikum let's
see what we can do together man thank
you for watching the d show continue to
tune in every week
in the meantime you can watch this
episode here or this one right here
support us on our patreon page
follow us
like us subscribe right now so you can
get all of our episodes sent to you
directly we'll see you next time peace
be with you assalamu alaikum